we said a minute ago this is the
greatest story of the week and it's only
monday we may have undersold it it's
only what june
7th we can say this is probably the best
story of the month
of june 2021 here's how it begins a
couple days ago sandy cortez of
westchester complained online that her
grandmother in puerto rico lives in
poverty because
of big orange she put up a picture of
her grandmother's house this is her home
she wrote
trump blocked relief money for puerto
rico well matt walsh is often on this
show
felt a twinge of empathy so he set up a
fundraiser a gofundme for sandy cortez's
grandmother
but neither one of them wanted the money
matt walsh is the compassionate host of
the matt walsh show
and joins us tonight with an update to
this poignant tale
of aid refused matt walsh first of all
thank you
for doing what sandy cortez herself
didn't do which is trying to help her
her abuela her grandmother what happened
here
yeah and thank you for giving me a
chance to talk about my philanthropy
which has been a big passion of mine
since
last week but uh listen she
she claimed that uh that her mother's
been living in her grandmother rather
has been living in this
in this dilapidated shack i guess for
four years since the hurricane
and she's a wealthy single woman who has
two apartments and a tesla that she just
recently bought apparently
she for whatever reason refused to help
her own grandmother and so
we said all right well you know what
we'll get together and we'll raise the
money we raised
a hundred thousand dollars in ten hours
okay we could we probably could have
raised a million dollars if they let the
fundraiser continue
but someone someone uh
big scare quotes around it in abuela's
family
shut down the fundraiser about 10 hours
into it and said that she doesn't want
the money now this raises a lot of
questions like for example
does this mean that abuela really wasn't
in the dire straits as it was
presented to us or would would aoc
prefer for her grandmother to live in
that state
suffering rather than to take money from
us i think either
way it's um it's it's
sort of scandalous i think on aoc's part
well it's a little bit weird that it was
left to you to help
ocasio-cortez's grandmother i mean i i
think of you as a kind of
i don't know caped crusader for good a
white knight in this world but i mean
shouldn't aoc be a little ashamed of
this
yeah i mean i and and obviously look
i've already put my i've put my hat in
the ring if anyone wants to nominate me
for a nobel peace prize i will
accept it it doesn't mean anything
anyway so you might as well give it to
me
but it is it is interesting that she
would that she would leave her
grandmother like that
and you know the thing is she said well
i'm focused on the systemic problems and
the government was supposed to solve
this problem
well it does show that actually you
don't have to wait around
for the system to solve every problem
sometimes free individuals can just get
together
and but this is a problem we could have
solved not just for abuela but
they could have taken the money fixed
the the ceiling bought her some
furniture she clearly needs
and then they could have taken the rest
of the money and and and helped the
neighbors they could have helped the
whole community
with these funds yeah but uh they
preferred not to do that
i'm starting to think maybe helping
people isn't the point for a casual
quartet
i'm so glad you were able to talk about
your philanthropy your passion for
helping mount walsh the great mount
walsh thank you
thank you see that that's a good story
we didn't oversell it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else